mes chers collègues
mesdames la ministre c'est un plaisir de
vous recevoir pour la première fois
devant notre commission
vous connaissez bien le Sénat pour y
avoir siéger entre 2011 et 2017 et vous
étiez d'ailleurs vice-président de la
commission des affaires sociales
depuis au-delà de vos fonctions des Luc
local vous avez également été président
du conseil d'administration de l'Agence
nationale de la cohésion des territoires
un opérateur récent et cher à notre
commission puisque notre commission
avait examiné au fond le texte portant
création de la NCT sur le rapport de
notre collègue Louis-Jean de Nicolay
votre audition aujourd'hui est
l'occasion pour nous d'aborder de
nombreux sujets de cohésion territoriale
qui sont au coeur des compétences de
notre commission mais aussi des
questions budgétaires l'Assemblée
nationale examine en ce moment le projet
de loi de finances pour 2023 et nous
ferons le même exercice dans quelques
semaines dans ce contexte après votre
intervention luminaire je passerai en
priorité la parole à notre collègue
Louis-Jean de Nicolaï qui rapporteur
pour avis du budget des programmes 112
et 162 de la mission des territoires du
conte d'affectation spéciale financement
des aides ou collectivités pour
l'électrification rurale et du programme
119 de la mission relations avec les
collectivités territoriales pour ma part
avant de vous céder la parole je
souhaiterais dire quelques mots du
budget 2023 et évoqué plusieurs travaux
récents de notre commission qui je
l'espère pourront inspirer l'action du
gouvernement pour le quinquennat qui
commence
s'agissant tout d'abord du budget je
rappelle que 27 programmes transversaux
concourent à la politique d'aménagement
du territoire pour un total d'environ
8,5 milliards d'euros de crédits
budgétaire et 13 milliards d'euros de
dépenses fiscales
plus spécifiquement des dotations qui
nous intéressent particulièrement au
titre du programme 119 je parle bien sûr
de la dotation d'équipement des
territoires ruraux DETR et de la
dotation de soutien à l'investissement
local la décile son stable
respectivement à un milliard d'euros et
570 millions d'euros
l'abondement de la des cils
exceptionnelle en 2022 n'est pas
reconduit l'emploi de l'expression
exceptionnelle nous a mis sur la voie
mais nous aurions aimé naturellement
nous et les élus locaux aimer voir ce
montant reconduit face notamment à
l'ampleur des rénovations énergétiques
des bâtiments publics qui convient de
mener dans les années prochaines
pour le programme sans doute je constate
avec satisfaction qu'il retrouve son
niveau d'avant covid et d'avant plan de
relance comme s'il était engagé en son
temps Jacqueline Gouraud il est même
légèrement augmenté cette année
d'environ 85 millions d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement et 16 millions
d'euros en crédit de paiement
fin de contribuer au financement de la
nouvelle génération de contrats de
planétari région
pour sa part la NTT ne voit sa
subvention augmentée que d'environ 2,6
millions du fait d'une mesure de
périmètre et la ligne dédiée à
l'ingénierie de projets n'évoluent pas
voilà pour ce rapide tour d'horizon des
principaux programmes de droit commun
qui nous intéresse globalement je note
qu'il s'agit plus d'un budget de
stabilité que d'un budget que je
pourrais appeler de conquêtes je
conclurai madame Lamy sur deux points
premièrement la question du futur fond
vert fond dédié aux collectivités qui
sera particulièrement précieux pour se
tenir les collectivités dans la
transition écologique et énergétique et
aussi et surtout dans l'adaptation
changement climatique
des arbitrages récents ont conduit à
augmenter son montant d'environ 2
milliards d'euros mais son
fonctionnement est les modalités de
décaissement de ces fonds ne sont pas
encore très clairs pouvez-vous nous en
dire plus sur le montant de son de ce
fond et sur son fonctionnement
ensuite sur la mission France 2030 qui
prend le relais du plan de relance
l'inscription de crédit dédié à de
nombreuses politiques de cette mission
France 2030 ne facilite pas la
lisibilité du budget pouvez-vous nous
rappeler et devant la commission pour le
périmètre ministériel qui est le vôtre
les crédits de la mission France 2030
qui concourent particulièrement à
l'action de votre ministère de ses
opérateurs j'en viens au récent travaux
récent travaux de la commission qui
s'inscrivent en complémentarité de
plusieurs programmes nationaux mis en
place par le précédent gouvernement et
que le Président de la République et la
première ministre ont annoncé vouloir
prolonger je pense aux mesures de
l'agenda rural aux outils contractuels
entre État et collectivités aux maisons
France service et bien sûr au programme
Action coeur de ville et petite ville de
demain sur lesquels j'en suis sûr notre
collèguerémy Cointreau ne manquera pas
de vous interroger compte tenu de son
récent en rapport rendu au nom de la
délégation sénatoriale ou territoriales
l'année dernière alors que le rythme de
travail de l'Assemblée nationale était
pour le moins réduit dans le contexte
des élections présidentielles et
législatives notre commission a mis en
place une mission d'information sur les
perspectives de la politique
d'aménagement du territoire animée par 5
rapports
dans ce cas nos collègues ont publié 5
rapports d'informations thématiques 43
mesures pour le soutien du commerce en
milieu rural 20 mesures pour assurer la
cohésion numérique dans les territoires
32 propositions pour renforcer l'axe
territorial aux soins face à l'expansion
des déserts médicaux sujets chers à
notre commission 14 propositions pour
une meilleure insertion de la logistique
dans l'environnement urbain et cette
proposition pour améliorer la sécurité
des ouvrages d'art en particulier les
ponts routiers
je n'aurais donc plus qu'une question à
vous poser madame la ministre quand
comment le gouvernement compte-t-il s'y
prendre et quand il prend appui sur les
propositions que le Sénat lui a fait
pour faire de que les grands principes
d'égalité de coopération de protection
et de compensation qui guide la
politique d'aménagement du territoire
plus demeurer une réalité pour tous nos
comprériotes et en particulier pour les
milieux les millions de concitoyens qui
vivent dans les zones rurales en un mot
quelle dynamique avez-vous l'intention
d'insuffler à notre politique
d'aménagement du territoire pour les
prochaines années nous évoquerons tout à
l'heure grâce aux questions de mes
collègues un autre sujet d'importance
majeur pour les élus de notre commission
je veux parler
de l'avenir des zones de revitalisation
rurale les aiderrai je vous remercie
madame la ministre et vous aide bien
volontiers la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je suis en effet
très heureuse d'échanger avec vous cet
après-midi à la fois sur la feuille de
route de mon ministère mais aussi sur
les mesures du projet de loi de finance
2023 qui concerne les collectivités
territoriales je tiens évidemment en
avant-propos saluer le travail précieux
que fait votre commission cherche
Jean-François Longeot pour penser de
manière renouvelée l'aménagement de nos
territoires les défis du réchauffement
climatique se font toujours pressants
comme en témoignent une fois encore
malheureusement les intempéries qui ont
frappé ce lundi plusieurs communes des
Hauts-de-France dans la somme du
Pas-de-Calais de l'Oise mais aussi de
l'Eure il nous faut donc accélérer la
transition écologique dans tous les
territoires au service de du
développement durable je crois que c'est
une priorité d'action de notre
gouvernement pour ce nouveau quinquennat
c'est aussi un sujet dont vous vous êtes
emparé depuis longtemps et lors des
rencontres que j'ai eues avec plusieurs
d'entre vous ces dernières semaines j'ai
pu constater que nous partageions la
même ambition nous discutions ont été
menées dans un esprit très constructif
et je tiens à vous en remercier un souci
commun de l'intérêt général qui je le
sais guidera également cette audition
vous avez eu l'occasion aussi
d'auditionner ces dernières semaines
mesdames et messieurs et sénateurs
plusieurs de mes collègues du
gouvernement Clément Beaune Hervé
Berville ainsi Agnès panière une hachée
ils ont déjà pu vous éclairer je n'en
doute pas sur la ligne que nous portons
collectivement au sein du gouvernement
ainsi que sur les délimitations de nos
périmètres ministériels aussi je
voudrais aborder plus spécifiquement
dans ce propos la question de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable sous l'angle des
relations entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales
vous le savez les enjeux auxquels sont
confrontés les territoires sont
conséquents à la fois sur le court terme
avec la crise énergétique et l'inflation
que nous connaissons mais aussi sur le
long terme je l'ai dit avec la nécessité
d'accélérer la transition écologique
partout en France en réalité ce ne sont
pas là vos problèmes distincts c'est
seulement en changeant en profondeur
notre modèle de société pour le rendre
plus durable que nous pourrons surmonter
le plus longtemps les défis du temps
présent face à l'urgence l'État a décidé
d'être à vos côtés aux côtés des
collectivités territoriales tout comme
l'état les accompagnent dans le chantier
de grande ampleur que représente leur
transition écologique mais cette action
de l'État indispensable ne peut être
pensée de manière verticale pour être
pleinement efficace l'Etat doit être
accompagnateur et non prescripteur au
service des projets portés par les élus
qui connaissent le mieux les atouts de
leur territoire c'est un changement en
profondeur auquel nous avons donné une
forte accélération lors du précédent
mandat et dont porte déjà la marque de
nombreux dispositifs d'aménagement que
nous avons porté au travers des deux
programmes actions cœur de ville et
petite ville de demain tout d'abord je
crois que d'une façon complémentaire il
permet à partir des centres urbains de
donner un élan nouveau à des bassins de
vie entier action cœur de ville je le
rappelle rapidement c'est ta date 5
milliards d'euros intégralement engagés
pour valoriser les centres de 234 villes
moyennes L'Oréal et je précise avec nos
partenaires la banque des territoires
actions logements
Lana et
d'autres partenaires qui sont venus se
rajouter au fil du temps dans ces
programmes les résultats nous semblent
tangibles les habitants ont pu constater
l'ampleur des travaux replie la
rénovation des centres anciens la
dynamisation des commerces et du
tourisme le réaménagement des mobilités
ou encore la création de nouveaux
espaces verts cette amélioration de
l'attractivité des centres-villes et
quantifiable il résulte des actions
entreprises dans le cadre du programme
et nous avons pu constater une hausse de
la fréquentation des centres-villes de
15%, malgré la pandémie je le souligne
et une hausse forte des ventes de
l'immobilier de 17%. nous préparons en
ce moment l'acte 2 d'action cœur de
ville pour accentuer encore sa portée
notre objectif est de soutenir davantage
des projets de valorisation liées à la
transition écologique j'ai présidé il y
a trois semaines le comité des
financeurs et cela a permis de faire un
point précis ensemble sur les
engagements de chacun de nos partenaires
cette phase 2 veut être ambitieuse et la
première ministre aura l'occasion dans
les semaines qui viennent dans dévoiler
les grands actes stratégiques petite
ville de demain c'est 3 milliards
d'euros mobilisés également avec nos
partenaires de l'État et je dirais avec
les partenaires par l'État et les
partenaires pour penser le réaménagement
des centres urbains de 1600 communes de
moins de 20 000 habitants jusqu'en 2026
2026 c'est aussi la date de prolongation
du programme Action coeur de ville
d'ores et déjà plus de 25% des montants
ont été engagés pour petite ville de
demain et surtout
876 chefs de projets et plus de 22.000
logements ont déjà été rénovés je
souhaite que nous puissions continuer à
dynamiser ce programme à la fois pour le
rendre plus opérationnel et surtout pour
l'orienter davantage sur des projets en
lien avec la transition éc
il nourrira d'ailleurs nos politiques
publiques sur la couverture mobile
l'objectif fixé était d'atteindre la
couverture 4G par au moins un opérateur
pour 85 % du territoire d'ici fin 2022 à
date cet objectif est déjà dépassé
puisque 90% du territoire est déjà
couvert
sur le très haut débit fixe le but est
d'assurer d'ici fin 2022 l'accès au très
haut débit fixe à tous les Français et
de généraliser la fibre optique d'ici
2025 cet objectif apparaît atteignable
puisqu'en début de l'année 2022 70% des
locaux étaient déjà raccordables à une
offre de fibre optique contre moins de
25% en 2017
l'agenda rural a également permis la
réinstallation des services publics au
plus près des habitants avec notamment
les espaces France services 2400 ont été
créés à ce jour dont 120 bus itinéraire
qui permettent de couvrir les
territoires les plus éloignés à la fin
de l'année notre pays contrat 2600
maisons France service au delà de
l'objectif initial d'un espace par
canton partout en France c'est guichet
et ses espaces France services
permettent d'exploiter le potentiel
numérique au service des territoires
mais surtout ils offrent des points de
contact essentiels pour nos concitoyens
avec une offre de service public menée
par 9 partenaires dans ce domaine nous
sommes en train d’ailleurs avec
Stanislas Guérini de préparer là aussi
un acte 2 pour les maisons France
services il nous semble en effet qu'un
certain nombre de territoires ne
seraient pas suffisamment couvert et ne
répondrait pas suffisamment à l'attente
de nos concitoyens
l'état accompagnateur et non pas
prescripteur apporte aussi son concours
financier en termes d'ingénierie pour
des élus locaux de façon importante
cette logique s'incarne également dans
le dispositif territoire d'industrie ce
dispositif contractuel a permis de
lancer une belle dynamique de
réindustrialisation depuis les
territoires en s'appuyant en priorité
sur les intercommunalités territoire
d'industrie c'est plus de 2 milliards
d'euros engagés dans près de 542
intercommunalités qui constituent le
bassin de vie de près de 30 millions de
Français les territoires d'industrie
témoignent de l'engagement du
gouvernement à une différenciation
toujours plus forte de nos politiques
publiques et notre volonté de
réindustrialiser notre pays d'une façon
plus équilibrée
nous en poursuivrons la mise en œuvre en
nous appuyant sur les retours qui nous
sont faits mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je voudrais aussi aborder avec
vous l'objectif 0 artificialisation
nette le fameux âne qui fait l'objet au
Sénat d'ailleurs d'une mission conjointe
de contrôle
le constat que nous partageons tous Je
j'ose le dire c'est la nécessité de
limiter à l'échelle de notre pays la
trop grande artificialisation des
surfaces afin de mieux lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique afin de mieux
préserver la biodiversité et afin de
mieux valoriser nos paysages nous
partageons je crois aussi la même
conviction ce sont les élus locaux qui
doivent être les pilotes ce sont eux qui
connaissent le mieux leur territoire
leurs besoins et qui ont depuis toujours
montré un certain souci de développement
harmonieux de leur territoire
il n'a pas il n'a jamais été question en
tout cas avec Christophe Béchu c'est
notre philosophie d'imposer d'en haut
des contraintes incompatibles avec la
valorisation des territoires ruraux
notamment depuis le début notre
gouvernement a poursuit une logique de
différentialisation et de
territorialisation dans le déploiement
de cette mesure de la loi climat et
résilience c'est au niveau de la région
que se construisent les équilibres et
les consensus en fondant les nouveaux
schémas régionaux d'aménagement et de
développement durable et d'égalité des
territoires les stradettes sur les
conclusions des conférences des schémas
de cohérence territoriale nous avons
ainsi avec Christophe Béchu repoussé de
6 mois le rendu des conférences cotes
jusqu'au 22 octobre par l'intermédiaire
de la loi 3DS à la demande des élus
locaux
sur la question des deux décrets
d'applications du mois d'avril
concernant la nomenclature et le mode de
calcul de l'objectif zan nous sommes
prêts à la discussion dans les limites
bien sûr du texte de loi qui encadre
notre action les élus doivent pouvoir
continuer à développer des espaces
naturels et de loisirs sans utiliser une
partie de leurs droits à construire et
il apparaît légitime de prendre en
compte les efforts de renaturation qui
seraient fait par les élus d'ici 2030
une instruction sur le mode de calcul
des espaces naturels agricoles et
forestiers et d'ailleurs en cours et je
sais que ici au Sénat Christophe BECHU a
réuni les associations d'élus pour
travailler tout sur tous les points de
friction qui existent dans la mise en
oeuvre de notre impératif de sobriété
foncière j'ai je lui ai redemandé de
m'assurer que dans l'esprit de
l'éducation de la loi les projets
d'intérêt nationaux ou régionaux leur
surface serait sortie des zones
habitables ou aménageables dans
l'application de la loi nous en avons
reparlé aujourd'hui à l'heure du
déjeuner et par exemple je prends dans
les hauts de France les 2200 hectares du
canal senor devrait être sortis des
zones aménageables attention vous me
dites bravo vous je l'apprécie mais il
va falloir ramener sur un amendement
législatif pour pouvoir y arriver mais
Christophe meschute m'assure que nous
aurons un arbitrage favorable et puis
nous arriverons d'abord au Sénat ça sera
plus simple vous le voyez
c'est ça vous le voyez l'État ne veut
pas vous contraindre et imposer de façon
verticale il faut que nous prenions en
compte toutes les propositions qui nous
sont faites pour atteindre le zan sans
compromettre le développement des
territoires
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
l'état accompagnateur et non pas
prescripteur c'est aussi un budget pour
2023 qui donne aux collectivités les
moyens d'agir et d'investir dans le
contexte d'inflation et de hausse des
prix de l'énergie que vous connaissez un
soutien accru de l'État était
indispensable c'est pourquoi en plus du
filet de sécurité mis en place dans le
PLFR et de la reconduction du bouclier
tarifaire qui permettent de faire face à
l'urgence du moment nous avons souhaité
défendre avec la première ministre une
hausse de la DGF de 320 millions d'euros
dont 200 millions seraient la dotation
de solidarité rurale c'est inédit depuis
2013 depuis 13 ans pardon excusez-moi de
cette façon 95% des communes et des
intercommunalités devraient voir leur
dotation stabilisée si ce n'est pas
augmenté
avec l'impératif de maîtrise de notre
dépense publique cette augmentation de
320 millions d'euros c'est un geste
important du gouvernement à l'égard des
collectivités et des élus locaux
sur la suppression de la CVAE
permettez-moi de dire quelques mots son
but c'est de permettre à notre pays de
gagner en compétitivité sans
compromettre les ressources de nos
collectivités elle sera en effet
intégralement compensée par
l'attribution d'une part supplémentaire
de TVA et de sa dynamique et qui dès
2023 sera dessinée au territoire qui
accueille de nouvelles activités
économiques selon des critères que nous
établirons de façon concertée et qui
permettront de maintenir le lien entre
les collectivités et le dynamisme
économique de leur territoire la
compensation de 2023 correspondra bien
aux sommes que l'État aurait dû reverser
au collectivités territoriales en 2023
au titre de la CVAE et je vous confirme
il n'y aura pas d'année blanche l'État
ne gardera rien notre souci de protéger
les marges de manœuvre des collectivités
transparaît également dans le maintien
de leur dotation d'investissement des
cils des sites des pvde à un montant de
près de 2 milliards d'euros comme
l'année précédente
pour parler plus spécifiquement du
programme 112 ces crédits sont en net
augmentation par rapport à l'année
précédente une hausse notamment liée à
la nouvelle génération de contrats de
plan état région la NCT quant à elle
voit son enveloppe confortée au service
de ses missions indispensables pour les
collectivités ces ressources renforcées
offrent aux collectivités une lisibilité
sur le long terme elle leur permettent
de continuer à investir en particulier
pour la transition énergétique c'est
pourquoi le projet de loi de finances
pour 2023 prévoit aussi d'abord
d'augmenter d'un tiers des moyens
consacrés à la dotation biodiversité
pour 2023 ils avaient déjà été doublés
en 2022 et ils atteindront désormais 30
millions d'euros cette mesure apporte
des moyens nouveaux aux communes qui
sont classées par que national zone
Natura 2000 ou dorénavant aussi parc
naturel régional deuxièmement ce projet
de loi de finance permet de mettre en
oeuvre le fond vert monsieur le
Président que vous avez abordé d'un
montant de 2 milliards d'euros
l'ensemble des projets illigibles et
leur caractéristiques doivent encore
être précisées et la première ministre a
d'ores et déjà annoncé que 200 millions
d'euros seront dédiés au département la
méthode d'attribution du fond est bien
arrêté elle se fera selon des règles
simples décentralisées et sans appel à
projet je crois que ce point est
important tout partira des initiatives
des élus selon une méthode lisible et
reconnue celle du dialogue entre les
élus et leur préfet de département ou de
région
par ailleurs je sais que vous êtes
saisis de l'enjeu des feux de forêt qui
avait fait l'objet qui a fait l'objet
d'un rapport d'information de Messieurs
Bassy de Madame Loisier messieurs Martin
et Monsieur Ritman au mois d'août et je
voulais vous dire la pleine mobilisation
du Gouvernement sur ce sujet après l'été
terrible que nous avons vécu il nous
faut agir sur la prévention vous l'avez
souligné ainsi qu'en termes de moyens
c'est tout l'objet de nos travaux au
niveau national avec les élus locaux et
avec nos partenaires européens le
président de la République recevra
d'ailleurs ce vendredi les acteurs
investis dans la lutte contre les feux
de l'été et interviendra sur cette
question
vous le voyez l'État est au rendez-vous
dans la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique à la fois pour en prévenir et
en combattre les effets ainsi que pour
mener à bien la transition de notre
société je m'arrête là monsieur le
Président et je me propose de répondre à
l'ensemble de vos questions
merci
et pour ces propos liminaires merci pour
vos informations sur
sur le zan et merci pour la réponse à
mes questions je vais donner la parole à
Louis-Jean de Nicolaï Rémy pintro à
Philippe Tabarro pour Pascal Martin
Bruno Belin et Jean-Pierre corviset
madame dema allez merci monsieur le
Président Madame ministre le président
de l'Anjou tout à l'heure dans son
propre objectif à rappeler l'essentiel
des interrogations que nous nous posions
sur les sur les programmes à la fois 112
et 179 et 162 notamment sur la
diminution des crédits de la décile mais
qui sont dues à la fin du plan de
relance tel que c'était prévu ça
laissera au préfet le soin de
d'organiser différemment les soutiens
aux collectivités moi je souhaitais
simplement vous interroger madame la
ministre sur cinq sujets tout d'abord
l'Agence nationale de la cohésion des
territoires vous en doutez dans les
crédits sont relativement stables et qui
voit ses actions sur le territoire se
développaient fortement à ce sujet
500 projets ont été
accompagner directement par l'agence et
je crois 330 ou 350 ont été accompagnés
par les partenaires privés nous nous
posons aussi la question de savoir si la
relation avec les collectivités
territoriales notamment des départements
en région ou pays ou Communauté de
Communes là aussi bénéficient de soutien
de l'agence et et si une meilleure
collaboration pourrait être plus
envisagée deuxième question quid de la
pâte la pâte la prime d'aménagement du
territoire elle est supprimée est-ce
qu'il est est-il prévu une politique de
remplacement doit-on considérer que
seuls les territoires industrie
bénéficieront d'aide maintenant et les
autres territoires qui auraient dans le
cas de réindustrialisation des
entreprises qui viendraient ne
pourraient pourraient bénéficier ou pas
de soutien
dans le cadre des zonages aussi deuxième
question ou troisième question plutôt
dans le cadre des zonages de soutien à
l'attractivité
des raisons de revitalisation des
commerces il y a eu tout un programme
qui a été monté dont j'ai oublié le nom
mais qui a été monté sur la réalisation
des commerces ça met beaucoup de temps
je sais pas si on peut donner une
accélération à cela mais en milieu
rurale c'est une grande inquiétude
pouvez-vous aussi nous faire dans la
quatrième question un point sur l'agenda
rural et son déploiement comme vous avez
évoqué quelques quelques idées et
cinquième et dernière question dans le
programme 162 il y a tout un programme
sur la reconquête de l'eau en Pays de la
Loire et de la qualité de l'eau en Pays
de Loire vous savez que le cette année
particulièrement le problème de l'eau
est un problème très aigu et que par
conséquent les soutiens qui peuvent être
faits pour les collectivités enfin les
collectivités territoriales qui
souhaitent reconquérir la qualité de
l'eau pour permettre à tout le monde en
bénéficier et quelque chose d'important
je veux savoir si ce programme vous
comptez le développer au niveau de votre
ministère
merci chers
moi je vais évoquer un sujet parce que
le sujet de les petits villes de demain
et actions cœur de ville on l'a vu
largement en délégation des
collectivités mais je rappelle
simplement les quelques propositions que
nous avons fait c'est-à-dire
les fonds dédiés pour les petits vis de
demain qui me paraît assez important
aujourd'hui on est on essaie de piocher
dans la DETR dans des fonds qui sont
déjà actifs et qui finalement contribue
à enlever des moyens à d'autres projets
communaux dans les départements donc
c'est important je pense de faire des de
mettre en place des fonds dédiés
vraiment pour les petits villes de
demain de remettre en place un fond pour
les commerçants le physac était une
bonne mesure pour aider les
commerçants à mettre aux normes leur
magasin et je pense qu'il va faire
remettre en place
aussi
un genre de fonds Isaac et puis de
mettre aussi en place le dispositif de
Normandie pour
au service des commerces là aujourd'hui
c'est uniquement les logements mais je
pense que les commerces seraient très
intéressé pour avoir du donormandie moi
je voudrais surtout évoqué un sujet
d'ailleurs qui a été l'objet d'une
question d'actualité tout à l'heure
c'est le l'avenir des zones de
revitalisation rurale
on a eu l'occasion également d'en
discuter dernièrement mais depuis
l'Association des maires de France a
produit un document de propositions sur
le sujet alors je voulais savoir ce que
vous pensez des propositions qui sont
avancées par l'AMF
quels sont les pistes de travail
actuel du gouvernement au sujet des
Ederer et puis est-ce que les Ederer
font-elles partie de votre feuille de
route entre vous et Madame madame Faure
et je rappelle que les communes qui ont
continué à bénéficier des effets du
classement
sans répondre aux critères de la
nouvelle réforme sortiront du zonage au
31 décembre 2023
et je crois qu'il faut que dès
maintenant on avance sur ce sujet et
qu'on fasse des propositions
nous en avons fait des certain nombre de
propositions avec Bernard delcro madame
espagnol dans un rapport qui a été fait
voilà un peu plus d'un an
et puis là nous avons une étude d'impact
qui est
d'évaluation qui est en cours au sein de
la ménagement et du développement
durable de la commission
donc on verra comment les choses vont se
passer mais je crois qu'il faut qu'on y
travaille on tout le monde tient ce
dispositif
ZRR et nous croyons tous qu'il doit être
non seulement préservé mais renforcer
renforcée parce que jusqu'à aujourd'hui
on a très peu communiqué sur les ZRR
beaucoup se sont installés sans savoir
que le dispositif était était installé
depuis longtemps et d'ailleurs les défis
en font très peu de très peu de
communication les publicités on ne sait
pourquoi mais je crois qu'il faut
vraiment qu'on travaille sur un
dispositif qui répond aux attentes de
des cabinets d'infirmières de kiné de
médecins et on a l'intime conviction que
la ruralité
est porteuse d'avenir
et qu'elle était déterminée par la
préservation d'outils
existant à l'image des et derrière et
donc on fera des propositions à l'issue
de du travail que nous allons faire avec
l'étude d'impact au sein de la
commission d'aménagement du territoire
mais je voudrais avoir votre vision sur
le sujet
merci cher collègue je vais passer la
parole à un autre collectivité du tabaco
oui madame la ministre comme vous le
savez le climat est rude pour les
collectivités les problèmes s'amoncelle
inflation énergie absorption du point
d'indice questionnement sur la tvae
révision des valeurs des bases locatives
ou encore le rejet légitime du projet de
favoriser la Sion de l'immigration dans
les zones rurales dans ce tumulte sous
la tutelle de deux ministres vous devez
plaider pour les collectivités alors
qu'elles sont bridées par un état plutôt
ingrat qui les charges beaucoup et être
peu bon ça c'est dit maintenant je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur un
point du programme 122 de la mission
relation avec les collectivités
territoriales dans le cadre du PLF au
nom de mon excellent collègue Pascal
Martin et je serai également très
attentif à votre réponse
puisque mon département ou notre
département des Alpes-Maritimes avec
Patricia dema
a été comme vous le savez terriblement
sinistré par la tempête Alex
des dans les éléments performance il est
indiqué que le délai moyen pour les
versement de l'aide aux collectivités
territoriales pour leur bien non naturel
dans le cadre de la procédure
d'indemnisation pour les dommages causés
par les intempéries et supérieures à un
an en 2022 mais devrait redescendre à 6
mois en 2023 j'ai donc deux questions
pouvez-vous revenir sur les événements
qui ont conduit à l'augmentation de ces
délais même pour les délégations
ministérielles où il y avait peu de gros
dossiers en jeu l'instruction dépasse
régulièrement les 9 mois et pouvez-vous
nous confirmer l'objectif des six mois
qui sont inscrits pour 2023 merci
ouais je voulais donner à la parole
encore à trois et puis comme vous voulez
mais c'est parce qu'il y en a qui
doivent partir
je vais donner la parole à Bruno Belin
si il y a peut-être des sujets qui sont
merci merci président ma mamie et des
sujets qui se regroupent toutes trois
sujets que je souhaitais évoquer avec
vous en moins de 3 minutes le premier ça
a déjà été évoqué par deux orateurs
précédents revenir sur la question du
commerce et notamment du commerce en
milieu rural vous savez que notre
commission a commis comme on dit avec
Serge gabarit de la commission des
Affaires Rico un rapport sur cette
question là où nous mettions de façon
centrale le rôle que pouvait jouer la
NCT et donc
notamment sur la question des fonds de
restructuration des locaux donc question
simple là-dessus que comptez-vous faire
des 43 propositions que nous avons fait
pour le commerce en milieu rural vous
savez que c'est difficulté réelles enfin
vous connaissez les chiffres parce que
vous les voyez aussi dans le territoire
vous êtes élu aujourd'hui deux communes
sur trois non plus de commerce et la
réalité la préfectuelle de ce début
d'automne ce sont les boulangeries les
boulangeries ferment les après les
autres sur des cas causes des factures
d'électricité et les plus petites sont
évidemment les plus fragiles deuxième
sujet c'est en lien avec cette ruralité
qui nous est chère et le commerce la
question des licences 4 qui devait être
un mécanisme simple de transformation
sur avis sur possibilité du maire on
voit bien parce que ça ça nous est
remonté par de nombreux élus que ça se
passe pas
voilà comme finalement l'imaginait avec
la loi 2019
ça peut paraître anecdotique mais en
milieu rural notamment et partout la
licence 4 voilà on crée aussi derrière
une activité de commerce un lien social
un lien d'animation et donc pour
reprendre juste une phrase de ce rapport
une vitrine allumée c'est un village qui
respire et donc c'est pour ça qu'on est
très attaché encore à essayer de sauver
quelques cafés en milieu rural troisième
sujet et j'en aurai terminé mais qui
touche là aussi beaucoup de
collectivités puisque nous avons
travaillé à la demande du président Jojo
sur un question rapport de suite qui
avait été faite sur les ponts l'état des
ponts suite à la catastrophe de gènes on
voit bien qu'en France on a encore une
méconnaissance à la fois sur l'état la
propriété ça peut paraître complètement
des manques à 10% près on ne sait pas
combien d'ouvrages d'art en France
comment fait-on pour aider les
collectivités sur cette question là
essentielle parce que derrière au bout
il y a des de sécurité et puis
évidemment on voulait mettre en
assistant à maîtrise d'ouvrage avec un
rôle central le cerema donc voilà pour
vous informer qu'il y aura sans doute
une proposition de loi sur ce sujet là
évidemment qu'on a besoin de votre
relais sur cette question essentielle si
la mamie merci président merci
chers
tout d'abord merci merci parce
qu'effectivement nous étions nombreux à
ce que le dans le cas de la loizanne les
projets d'intérêt nationaux et
supranationaux par exemple comme le
canal senor plus de 2000 hectares ne
soit pas impacté sur le compte des
communes rurales et puis le reste de
l'intervention sera complètement hors
sujet par broder cet après-midi madame
ministre ça n'est pas lundi dernier mais
dimanche dernier dans l'après-midi que
tornade d'une ampleur exceptionnelle à
traverser les hauts de France et je peux
vous dire que moi étant sur l'autoroute
A1 se retrouver à rouler à 20 à l'heure
dans cette tempête je n'étais pas fier
madame mamie dans mon département du
Pas-de-Calais deux communes distantes
pourtant de 16 km
billycours et un Decourt les canicours
ont été ravagés par cette tornade j'ai
accompagné avec d'autres de mes
collègues ici présents dès lundi après
le monsieur ministre de l'Intérieur venu
se rendre compte de la situation sur
place mais aussi d'abord de remercier
l'ensemble des services de sécurité quel
qu'il soit qu'il durant la nuit en plus
effectivement
intervenir sur place je peux vous dire
Madame les ministres que ce fut une
vision apocalyptique que l'on peut voir
malheureusement actuellement dans les
médias dans par rapport à un conflit
dans l'Est de l'Europe
madame lisse vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
que votre principal collaborateur est
l'ancien préfet du Pas-de-Calais
pensez-vous vous déplacer dans mon
département
parce que les mères aimeraient vous
rencontrer comme vous le savez mes chers
collègues le critère tornade n'est
malheureusement pas un critère pour la
reconnaissance de catastrophes
naturelles malheureusement et donc les
dégâts seront donc pris simplement pris
en charge par les assurances avec comme
vous le savez tous et tous l'application
d'une décote la même ministre lors de
vos déplacements viennent derrière vous
avec dans votre trou avec dans votre
trousse de secours des moyens financiers
pour que les communes sinistrés puissent
se reconstruire je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre j'aurais deux petites questions
à vous poser la première intéresse les
maires de la ruralité et leur difficulté
grandissante à recruter des secrétaires
de mairie alors que la majorité part en
retraite et que la relève n'est pas
assurée je voulais savoir quelles sont
les mesures que compte prendre le
gouvernement à la fois pour faciliter
les recrutements pour faciliter aussi la
montée en compétences de ces secrétaires
qui sont des collaboratrices
indispensables pardon au maillon
fondamental entre les élus et la
population monter en compétences vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure en évoquant
mon rapport sur l'inclusion numérique
monter en compétences par rapport à la
dématérialisation des services
ça c'est le premier sujet puis le
deuxième sujet qui est peut-être qui ne
concerne pas la ruralité mais plutôt les
zones très denses et je voulais parler
de la fibre le déploiement de la fibre
en zone très dense relève aujourd'hui
alors que les objectifs à atteindre en
2025 soit sont le 100% fibre il existe
aujourd'hui des zones blanches en zone
très dense là où les opérateurs n'ont
pas d'obligation de déploiement mais
pour le principal c'est l'opérateur
Orange où il y a effectivement des zones
blanches alors je voulais vous
interroger sur les intentions du
Gouvernement pour réviser de manière
urgente peut-être
l'appui des poteaux enedis qui
faciliterait le déploiement des réseaux
en zone très dense et puis aussi avoir
la certitude que tant que la complétude
ne sera pas atteinte le réseau cuivre ne
sera pas déposé
voilà mes deux questions merci
monsieur le Président alors j'avais une
question madame la ministre mais vous
avez répondu ma question portée sur le
fond vert et l'attribution je fais
partie de la mission de contrôle
n'est-ce pas sur la sobriété foncière et
je pense que effectivement la
distribution est très importante
qu'elle ne se fasse pas sous forme
d'appel à projet mais que les maires
puissent y accéder pour reconquérir les
centres Bours parce que c'est un des
aspect qui fera qui permettra aux maires
de d'intégrer vraiment la dimension
sobriété foncière et puis je voulais
vous dire aussi que je suis obligé de
vous quitter pour reprendre rejoindre
l'aéroport d'Orly et reprendre l'avion
dont vers l'Aveyron donc j'espère que
vous avez malgré ce qui est arrivé
n'est-ce pas à garder ce bon souvenir
l'aveyronie pour rien en espérant de ce
qui s'est passé la dernière fois en tout
cas vous êtes parti avec le soleil vous
êtes arrivés ici avec la pluie et je
crois que c'est ça la raison en tout cas
on vous souhaite de revenir en Aveyron
dans les meilleures conditions
la ministre
[Musique]
les réponses à mes collègues merci merci
monsieur le sénateur anglar je vous
souhaite un beau temps pour le retour
la première les premières questions
viennent du sénateur Louis-Jean de
nicolaïe d'abord sur la NCT je voudrais
rappeler que
cet accompagnement de la NCT est ouvert
à toutes les collectivités et qu'il peut
porter sur l'élaboration d'un projet de
territoire il permet la prise en charge
l'intégrale des prestations d'ingénierie
je le rappelle pour les communes de
moins de 3500 habitants gratuitement
voilà et cela représente à peu près 94%
des communes qui pourraient bénéficier
de ce dispositif alors vous me dites le
montant de 20 millions d'euros
d'ingénierie ne vous paraît pas
suffisant en fait en 2021 et il y avait
eu que 12 millions d'euros qui avaient
été engagés au titre de l'accompagnement
sur mesure donc l'état dans un souci de
rigueur budgétaire a souhaité reconduire
les 20 millions je pense que cela
devrait nous permettre de faire face
pour l'année prochaine au 1er mai 2022
il y avait à peu près 1000 projets qui
ont été accompagnés par l'agence et ses
partenaires j'ajoute d'ailleurs que le
fond vert comprendra également des
crédits spécifiquement destinés à
l'ingénierie qui viendront s'ajouter à
la ligne à générer général de la NCT
outre l'accompagnement sur mesure vous
le savez l'agence apporte aussi un
soutien aux collectivités à travers des
crédits dédiés monsieur sénateur
Pointreau à l'ingénierie de ces
programmes c'est par exemple les
programmes actions coeur de ville les
programmes petite ville de demain la NCT
contribue au financement des chefs de
projet
6 millions d'euros ça nous a coûté 6
millions d'euros en année 2021 en
complément du financement
apporté par le programme 112 et le
programme territoire d'industrie enfin
la NCT participe également à la start-up
d'État aide territoire dont la vocation
est de recenser l'ensemble des aides et
offre d'ingénierie à disposition des
collectivités territoriales il y a
300082 aides disponibles et qui sont
offertes par des porteurs d'aide qui ont
été recensés et elles couvre à peu près
87 thématiques ensuite vous m'avez
interrogé sur l'agenda rural
l'agenda rural il avait été lancé en
2019 par le Premier ministre Édouard
Philippe il poursuit aujourd'hui la mise
en oeuvre des 180 une mesure avec quatre
objectifs je vais les rappeler faire des
territoires ruraux les faire de l'anse
de la transition écologique renforcer
leur attractivité améliorer la vie
quotidienne des habitants et appuyer les
élus locaux dans leur action
aujourd'hui en terme d'avancer
enregistré depuis trois ans je dirais
qu'il y a d'abord une gouvernance et une
lisibilité
transversale renforcée de la ruralité
via une nouvelle définition des
ruralités et dans chaque sous-préfet il
va il y a déjà un certain nombre de Sous
Préfet qui dépendent de chaque ministère
concerné en transversalité qui sont des
référents à la ruralité dans chaque
département pour coordonner la mise en
oeuvre d'une route de la ruralité dans
leur département j'avoue que c'est ma
collègue Dominique Faure qui est
secrétaire d'État à la ruralité qui va
approfondir à certains nombres de
dossiers dans le cadre de cette ruralité
elle va lancer des un certain nombre de
mesures et surtout ce qu'elle appelle un
parlement de la ruralité qui sera réuni
avec elle et Christophe Béchu
ceci étant nous souhaitons une réponse
consistante à la demeure d'ingénierie
des collectivités rurales avec plusieurs
outils qui permettent le recrutement le
financement des postes au sein des
collectivités et beaucoup de
collectivités rurales ont mutualisé ces
postes de chargés de mission sur deux ou
trois communes pour faciliter le
recrutement parce que sur des petites
communes c'était difficile pour eux
d'avoir une activité
à temps plein
aujourd'hui si je veux vous donner
quelques chiffres clés je dirais qu'il y
a dans l'agenda rural 66
cette petite ville de demain les 2400
maisons France services
un point qui est important peut-être que
vous en avez entendu parler les campus
connectés
il y a je dirais 66 campus connectés en
milieu rural qui permette à des
étudiants de suivre des cours
d'université à distance dans un endroit
dédié de la commune et pour l'avoir vécu
dans ma commune je sais que cela
facilite quelquefois les études
supérieures pour des étudiants qui n'ont
pas acquitter leur foyer pour des
raisons financières je dirais
basiquement et qui peuvent faire une ou
deux années avec des points de rencontre
bien sûr dans les universités auxquelles
ils sont rattachés mais qui leur
facilitent la vie est dans ce dans ce
domaine sur la suppression des et le
dispositif qui va remplaçant la prime
d'aménagement du territoire la pâte
c'est une aide c'était une aide directe
à l'investissement des entreprises pour
promouvoir l'implantation et le
développement d'entreprise créatrice
d'emploi alors le choix a été fait de
mettre fin au dispositif en 2020 parce
qu'il y a finalement une redondance avec
d'autres
mécanismes que nous avons jugé plus
efficace et moins contraignant les aides
des collectivités territoriales mais
aussi les aides européennes par le biais
du fédère et donc la pâte était
finalement devenue assez marginal et
puis il y avait dans les indicateurs une
assez des résultats assez faibles alors
c'est là où à la pâte on succédé les
programmes portés par la NCT qui
permettent de mieux répondre aux enjeux
de développement économique et
d'aménagement du territoire et je pense
d'abord au programme territoire
d'industrie qui apporte un certain
nombre de réponses concrètes sur le
développement des compétences
industrielles sur la formation et la
mobilité des salariés et l'attractivité
des territoires et des
métiers industriels il y a aujourd'hui
146 territoires d'industrie qui
regroupent 542 à terre communalités au
niveau national
sur
l'avenir des zones de revitalisation des
commerces puisque nous avons après les
Ederer
ce dispositif d'exonération
pouvant être institué par les communes
et les EPCI dans la zone dans un zonage
fixé par arrêté n'a pas eu le succès
escompté malheureusement puisque
seulement 1,4% des communes éligibles
l'ont mis en œuvre je pense qu'on doit
réfléchir à notre dispositif
avec une réflexion commune peut-être
mais je sais que Dominique Faure est en
train de de s'en préoccuper
sur la qualité de l'eau dans les pays de
la loi
vous m'interrogez sur la question de
cette qualité des cours d'eau cette
question a fait l'objet d'une ligne
spécifique dans le contrat état région
signé en 2019 et je crois qu'il
bénéficie de crédible budgétaire propre
cette ligne budgétaire est portée par le
ministère de l'intérieur elle a été mise
en oeuvre en 2020 pour permettre à
l'État de poursuivre et d'intensifier
son action pour répondre aux enjeux liés
à la qualité des eaux ligériennes qui
étaient forts dégradées
pour les trois premières années de mise
en oeuvre les financements en permis
d'élargir les territoires dans lesquels
les agriculteurs peuvent bénéficier de
financement incitatif pour pratiques
culturelles ou vertueuse de l'eau et je
sais que 80% du territoire régional et
désormais éligible contre 30% auparavant
de nombreuses autres études
complémentaires sont envisagées à partir
de 2023 tant sur le volet quantitatif
que qualitatif de la ressource en eau je
crois que j'ai répondu aux questions du
sénateur Nicolaï
le sénateur point trop m'a interrogé sur
l'avenir des et derrière et des
différents zonages alors comme je disais
tout à l'heure dès 2020 le gouvernement
avait anticipé l'extinction de plusieurs
dispositifs zonés de soutien du
développement économique et de l'emploi
qui vont arriver à échéance en décembre
qui sont arrivés à échéance en décembre
2020 et il y avait chargé une mission
inspection de les évaluer dans la
qualité du
précédent rapport de parlementaire et
d'experts qui avaient analysé ces zones
ZRR la mission inter-respicion a conclu
à une relative
inefficacité des exonérations fiscales
social sur la création des
entreprises et de et sur l'emploi pour
autant ces exonérations sont perçus par
les entreprises et les collectivités
comme un signal
était perçu comme un signal positif de
l'État et une reconnaissance de la
vulnérabilité de leur territoire alors
u égard à l'ampleur des travaux
envisagés à la nécessité de disposer
d'une réelle phase de concertation entre
les acteurs économiques et sociaux et
les élus le gouvernement a proposé de
proroger de deux ans les zonages
arrivant à échéance au 31 décembre 2020
pour les emmener jusqu'au 31 décembre
2023 chez moi ça fait trois ans mais en
loi de finances 2022 ce délai
supplémentaire va nous permettre de
poursuivre les travaux sur la géographie
prioritaire les propositions développées
par Jean-Noël barreau dans son rapport
compte que c'est quand même un enjeu
pour l'attractivité des territoires
ruraux on est pleinement conscient de
l'intérêt de ces dispositifs et nous
allons étudier les meilleures options
après l'extinction de ce dispositif ZRR
évidemment
monsieur le sénateur Tabaro c'est ça le
troisième non il est parti
il revient alors j'attends qu'il soit
revenu monsieur le sénateur Belin
peut-être
alors sur la question des licences 4 et
des commerces c'est vrai que
ah pardon excusez-moi excusez-moi
l'agenda rural soutenait directement
plusieurs initiatives dans ce domaine
pour favoriser le maintien ou
l'installation des commerces dans les
territoires ruraux alors je pense aux
dispositif 1000 café mais qui n'a pas
été un succès phénoménal je vois combien
moi j'ai 55 alors ça c'est peut-être un
peu amélioré
c'est ça oui ou selon la police ouais
alors je revende je revendique de ne pas
être la police même si je dépends aussi
de l'intérieur
il y a aussi un certain nombre de
dispositifs comme comptoir de campagne
village vivant bistrot de pays et puis
moi j'avais visité chez Françoise Gatel
les le dispositif le label petite ville
de caractère qui permet Petite Cité de
Caractère autant pour moi qui me
paraissait être assez opportuns
finalement dans la revitalisation des
centres bourgs et qui pourrait peut-être
nous aider à développer ces centres
Bours mais encore une fois
j'allais dire vous pouvez faire appel à
notre ingénierie pour l'ingénierie de la
NCT pour améliorer les réponses qui sont
données sur les licences 4 pour créer
une faire une déclaration de création de
licence 4 dans les communes de moins de
3500 habitants dispose pas
moi je vois que 200 licence 4 ont été
créées c'est pas beaucoup mais est-ce
qu'elle le demande est-ce que les
communes le demandent il y en a eu 60%
de plus qu'en 2020 quand même donc je
crois que c'est peut-être un dispositif
à creuser et améliorer pour
pour développer les choses je pense que
ça fera partie aussi de la feuille de
route de Dominique Faure j'en parlerai
avec elle puisque nous allons travailler
ensemble
sur
vous m'interrogez sur la sécurité des
ponts
alors les boulangeries qui meurent je
peux vous dire que j'ai entendu la
réponse qu'a fait Bruno Le Maire à
l'Assemblée nationale hier en disant que
les aides le
filet de sécurité et
l'autre dispositif
le bouclier est tarifaire serait
appliqué au boulangerie donc si vous
voulez je creuse cette réponse là et je
vous la transmets pour les boulangeries
mais Bruno Le Maire a annoncé
officiellement hier enfin à l'Assemblée
nationale sur une question gouvernement
que les boulangers faisaient partie des
PME PMI qui bénéficieraient de ce
bouclier tarifaire
les ponts c'était
vous aussi oui donc sur les ouvrages
d'art le gouvernement avait consacré
dans le cadre du Plan France relance une
enveloppe de 40 millions d'euros
dessinés aux ouvrages d'art des communes
et je sais qu'il y en avait eu
d'ailleurs mais qui concernait plus
monsieur Tabarro dans avec la le cyclone
la tempête Alex et là aussi c'est le
cerema qui est venu en appui séréma qui
est aujourd'hui dans le l'enveloppe à
NCT et
la moitié des communes il y a beaucoup
de communes qui en dehors de la
situation extrême des communes
j'allais dire martyrisé par Alex il y a
eu un certain nombre d'ouvrages d'art
qui ont été recensés dont les montants
de travaux ont été évalués pour
un nombre de communes dans le cadre du
Plan France relance
fin juin 2022 la moitié des communes
bénéficiaires ont eu une visite de leurs
ouvrages qui correspond à 25000 ouvrages
visités ce sont un panel d'ouvrage parmi
les plus sensibles à l'échelle nationale
alors il y a pas d'enveloppe dédiée
financement de ces travaux qui relèvent
évidemment la compétence des communes ou
des départements ou des établissements
publics de coopération intercommunale
fiscalité propre l'État les a
accompagnés en termes d'expertise via
ces opérateurs dans la réalisation des
diagnostics je serai néanmoins vigilante
à ce que les dotations de soutien à
l'investissement local soit mobilisée
pour la sécurisation
de ces ouvrages d'art relevant de la
compétence des communes
pardon président ce que je peux
reprendre la parole oui bien sûr pardon
madame la ministre
ce sujet des ponts est grave on peut pas
aller chercher de la DETR les enveloppes
des deux des sous préfet vous le
connaissez comme moi chacun le sait
elles sont pas extensibles si on
complète dedans il y aura pas autre
chose pour les communes 40 millions pour
000 ouvrages d'art
160 euros par ouvrage d'art planète de
l'État il faut qu'on soit sérieusement
donné on est en pleine loi de finance il
y a un risque il faut absolument qu'on
réagisse voilà pardon président d'avoir
repris
non mais c'est un sujet effectivement
très sensible parce que c'est un sujet
d'abord il y a un certain nombre de
ponts qui n'appartiennent à personne
parce que personne n'en veut surtout pas
moi
effectivement les petites collectivités
qui même les plus grosses qui sont
confrontés et les petites où il y a des
fois deux trois ponts sur leur sur leur
territoire communal c'est compliqué et
c'est vrai que au niveau de la DETR
c'est pas possible alors nous on essaie
de creuser un petit peu au département
du Doubs pour voir si on peut essayer
d'apporter un peu un peu un peu un plus
avec les amandes de police mais ça va
pas faire non plus la rue Michel pour
les pour les collectivités c'est vrai
que c'est un c'est vrai que c'est un
très gros problème ces histoires de pont
et il y a des il y a des ouvrages qui
qui aujourd'hui soit ils sont réparés
immédiatement soit ils sont c'est fermé
parce qu'on ne peut plus mais on peut
plus y accéder tout à fait
alors ensuite il y a Monsieur
corbiset
vous m'avez parlé de la garantie
catastrophe naturelle qui couvre
l'indemnisation de bien assurés des
particuliers des entreprises et des
collectivités
victimes d'un phénomène
d'un phénomène naturel intense alors en
effet vous avez raison parce que on
l'obtient quand il y a des inondations
quand il y a des je vais dire des
mouvements de terrain ou alors une
sécheresse des sols ou des avalanches
etc alors les effets de tempête sont
exclus des dispositifs mais j'ose vous
dire que ces risques sont couverts par
les compagnies d'assurance en principe
au titre de la garantie tempête grêle ou
neige cette garantie TNG c'est une
extension obligatoire des contrats
d'assurance imposés par le législateur
et et donc il y a aucune reconnaissance
préalable de l'État qui soit nécessaire
pour que c'est bien endommagé par les
tornades soit indemnisés par les
assurances j'allais dire je pense que
c'est la déclaration de chaque
particulier malheureusement de
d'intervenir
pardon
je viens de viendrai je viendrai bien
sûr
madame de ma vous m'avez parlé des
secrétaires de mairie c'est en effet une
compétence qui se fait rare et je pense
que dans l'agglo dans laquelle je suis
c'est exactement la même chose
malheureusement elles sont
indispensables ils sont indispensables
au fonctionnement des communes de petite
taille essentiellement rurales alors il
y a des mesures de revalorisation
conséquente qui ont été prises le
Gouvernement a souhaité revaloriser la
nouvelle bonification indiciaire
qui serait attribué aux agents exerçant
ces fonctions dans les collectivités de
moins de 2000 habitants cela représente
alors géante de le dire que 56 euros
mensuels net c'est pas très bon pour ces
secrétaires de mairie il y a aussi la
revalorisation du point d'indice qui
peut leur être appliqué et là c'est plus
3 et demi pour cent
et à titre d'exemple c'est ce que je
voyais une secrétaire de mairie qui a 15
ans d'ancienneté le gars mensuel c'est
serait de 57 + 3 et demi pour cent
puisqu'il y a bon ça fait 100 euros à
tout casser
compte tenu de la forte hétérogénéité
des situations des agents je pense que
la création d'un cadre d'emploi
spécifique ne sera pas possible parce
que elles n'ont pas toutes les mêmes
fonctions au sein d'un cadre d'emploi
territorial
la réflexion pourrait peut-être
s'insérer dans les travaux de mon
collègue Stanislas Guérini qui à la
responsabilité de la fonction publique
territoriale il travaille sur des
parcours de carrière et sur la
rémunération
dans la fonction publique et donc je
peux lui signaler justement le cas de la
rémunération des secrétaires de mairie
qui en font un métier rare aujourd'hui
ceci étant
je ne sais pas si vous pouvez appliquer
les primes rives sceptes sur
les secrétaires de mairie il y a des
quelques leviers qui restent pour
améliorer leurs conditions de financière
de travail voilà mais je connais ce
sujet il est délicat et devient de plus
en plus difficile pour faire une petite
confidence dans mon territoire il y a
une petite boucle WhatsApp où les mers
font part de leur recrutement pour
savoir si certains veulent mutualiser
tel ou tel secrétaire de mairie voilà
je suis désolé mais j'ai pas de réponse
miracle merci je pense qu'il faudrait
peut-être aussi qu'on remette en place
les les formations pour l'exploiter de
mairie parce que c'est vrai que c'est
important que les les gens puissent se
former parce que c'est des métiers en
fait intéressant c'est les métiers
compliqués quand on fait deux heures
dans une commune 4h dans l'eau c'est
assez compliqué mais c'est très
intéressant oui les centres de gestion
sont pas toujours
notre sollicitons en tout cas dans
l'Oise n'ont pas de ce recettes miracle
non plus bien je vais donner la parole à
Cyril pelva et puis monsieur Dagbert et
Monsieur Gold et puis mais je vais
donner la parole à tous ceux qui restent
madame
Monsieur Hervé Gillet juste après madame
Préville monsieur Jeunet et Madame
blanche
et c'est un véritable sujet si vous
pouvez me dire quelques mots sur le
sujet je vous transmettrai une réponse
d'accord merci merci
[Musique]
climatique du zan mais également des
contraintes qui pèsent sur les finances
locales des collectivités je m'interroge
sur la vision du gouvernement en matière
de politique d'aménagement du territoire
ou plutôt sur l'absence de vision du
gouvernement pour l'aménagement du
territoire en effet aujourd'hui cette
politique semble se réduire à une
juxtaposition de programme 27 en tout
cas financiers et à un empilement de
dispositif que vous avez fort bien
énuméré et tout ce très bien décrit mais
l'ensemble ne semble pas porté de
planification
penser concerter et je voulais savoir si
un jour nous aurions la chance de
connaître votre vision du territoire
comment vous voyez l'équilibre entre les
villes et la campagne et comment on
intervient pour qu'il y ait des formes
de contrat entre les entre la campagne
et comment on a une vision également
équilibrée de tous ces territoires
ensuite je voulais évoquer l'étude
publiée il y a quelques jours par
l'Institut de l'économie pour le climat
qui est value à 12 milliards d'euros le
montant annuel des investissements
climats qui doivent être réalisés par
les collectivités afin d'atteindre les
objectifs de la Stratégie nationale bas
carbone en 2030 ce montant représente
presque 20% de leur budget
d'investissement soit deux fois plus que
ce qui est dépensé aujourd'hui
alors comment demander aux collectivités
de réaliser ces objectifs
environnementaux sans qu'ils en ait ni
les moyens financiers ni les moyens en
ingénierie aujourd'hui entre injonction
contradictoires passage en force
pression sur les finances locales les
collectivités au contraire perdent leurs
moyens leurs pouvoirs d'action comment
les restaurer pour mener à bien cette
transition écologique
je voulais également vous parler de la
mobilisation du fond vert par les
collectivités territoriales car
effectivement vous annoncez donc qu'il
sera simple déconcentré sans appel à
projet mais dès lors qu'elles ont
qu'elles en sera exactement le pilotage
comment sera-t-il appliqué dans les
territoires et comment s'effondre seront
finalement déployés avec quel suivi et
avec quel articulation avec la NCT et
enfin pour parler de la NCT rejoindre le
propos de Monsieur Nicolaï pour dire que
les moyens dédiés au soutien des
collectivités territoriales en matière
d'ingénierie au travers de la NCT non
que très peu évoluer depuis une année
pleine on va dire une mise en place du
dispositif en année pleine alors même
qu'il y a un manque criant
d'accompagnement des maires et qui ne
semble pas y avoir d'avancer
significative dans le de ce point de vue
là or on voit que le nombre de communes
aidé par ce dispositif de même par
action coeur de ville et petite ville de
demain est relativement limitée
vous-même vous disiez je crois 1000
sur notre 36000 communes mais peut-être
est-ce que je me trompe et j'ai mal
compris et que j'ai mal compris mais
néanmoins je voulais donc vous poser une
question d'ordre général comment est-ce
qu'on a une égalité on parvient à une
égalité entre les territoires et qu'en
est-il des indicateurs et de
l'évaluation des dispositifs pilotés par
la NCT je vous remercie beaucoup
monsieur le Président de m'avoir donné
la parole
merci vous savez je l'ai fait dans l'eau
parce qu'il y avait les les premières
demandes c'était au titre des
rapporteurs pour avis donc je et Cyril
pelvin m'a demandé il y a aussi
longtemps
mais j'ai eu des demandes j'ai eu des
demandes parce que voilà j'ai eu des
demandes qui ont été écrites voilà je
vous montrerai parce que en général je
fais pas le fanfaron j'ai eu des
demandes qui ont été écrites après et
j'ai eu des demandes qui ont été déjà
sur ma feuille qui avait déjà été faite
sur les rapporteurs voilà voilà le
pourquoi voilà pourquoi j'ai pas voulu
j'ai pas fait un choix en disant je fais
de ce côté là puis après je serai de ce
côté là non pas du tout c'est pas mon
tempérament
[Musique]
j'ai donné la parole à Cyril pelva
et puis après un monsieur gold monsieur
Dagbert monsieur Bigot monsieur Gillet
madame Préville monsieur Jeunet et
Madame Saint-Pé voilà
merci merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre actuellement certaines
communes soumises à la taxe sur les
logements vacants dispose d'une faculté
de majoration de la taxe d'habitation
sur la résidence secondaire
cependant de nombreuses communes de
montagne sont éligibles et voient les
prix de l'immobilier augmenter de façon
exponentielle sur leur territoire en
raison de résidence secondaire non
habitées une grande partie de l'année
cela conduit les locaux à se loger
toujours plus loin dans les vallées et
ainsi faire baisser la population
permanente de ces communes une
possibilité de majorer la taxe
d'habitation sur la résidence secondaire
en zone de montagne ou tout du moins
dans les stations classées de tourisme
permettrait de lutter contre ce
phénomène de l'effroi en complément des
nouveaux dispositifs mis en place par le
plan montagne qui nous pourrons à eux
seuls permettent de régler ce problème
il s'agit d'une mesure demander depuis
plusieurs années par les associations
d'éluses montagnes je pense notamment à
la NEM et à la MSM cependant le
gouvernement c'est jusqu'à présent
opposé à cette extension du périmètre
tout en se positionnant en même temps en
faveur du droit à la différenciation je
souhaiterais donc connaître madame la
ministre votre avis sur proposition et
savoir si le gouvernement s'opposera de
nouveau à des amendements visant à
instaurer cette majoration dans le cadre
du PLF et si tel est le cas pour quelle
raison de même si vous jugez cette
extension du périmètre inopportunes
envisagez-vous d'autres solutions pour
aider les communes à lutter contre les
lits froids
merci Monsieur gold oui merci président
madame la ministre moi je vais vous
parler à nouveau du programme petite
ville de demain qui a été abordé par un
des orateur précédent
programme qui était l'une des mesures
phares de l'agenda rurale en 2019 tout
comme sa grande sœur action cœur de
ville il remporte un vif succès auprès
des élus locaux et près de 1650 communes
en bénéficient toutefois si les élus
louent la méthode est particulièrement
le soutien d'ingénierie il pointe des
insuffisances notamment sur les
financements et sur la complexité la
lourdeur de la mise en oeuvre alors
convaincu de l'intérêt de ce programme
pour la vitalité et l'attractivité de
nos territoires et sachant que l'habitat
et la revitalisation commerciale sont
deux préoccupations majeures des petites
villes de demain moi je souhaiterais
savoir quelles sont les intentions du
Gouvernement concernant les postes de
manager de centre-ville qui
contrairement au poste de chargé de
projet ne sont financés que deux ans par
l'État
alors même que leurs actions leur action
s'inscrit dans la durée et puis
concernant l'aspect habitat j'aimerais
savoir si le gouvernement pourrait
envisager d'élargir l'intervention du
dispositif Action Logement à petite
ville demain parce que beaucoup de
programmes ne peuvent pas décoller en
raison des difficultés en matière de
financement de logement et puis je
m'excuse en avance je vais être obligé
de partir parce que j'ai un train donc
je regarderai avec
avec
je me ferai raconter le compte-rendu par
mes collègues
merci chers collègues monsieur Dagbert
merci monsieur le Président
ministre arrivé à ce stade de l'audition
bien évidemment un certain nombre de
sujets sont redondants je m'associe à
l'invitation lancée par mon collègue du
Pas-de-Calais Jean-Pierre corbizet
puisque j'étais à ses côtés et aux côtés
de Monsieur ministre de l'Intérieur
lundi lors de sa visite vous êtes la
bienvenue dans le Pas-de-Calais sur ce
site mais sur bien d'autres aussi et
sans doute pour des visites avec un tout
autre caractère je tiens quand même à
préciser qu'à la faveur de ce
déplacement monsieur le ministre a
insisté sur sur le mécanisme comme vous
venez de le rappeler à savoir que ce
sont les assurances qui qui vont agir
cependant il a rassuré également les
maires sur un certain nombre de biens
publics notamment les bâtiments
communaux et je pense notamment à
l'école qui a été fortement endommagée
et le concours éventuel que les
enveloppes du ministère de l'Intérieur
pourraient être mobiliser et apporter
leur concours sur ces travaux
j'ai aussi été témoin de ce que monsieur
le préfet du Pas-de-Calais réunissait
dès mardi les maires et les assureurs
pour justement mettre en place
tout ce qui va bien pour rendre les
choses plus fluides pour les citoyennes
et les citoyens de ces communes qui ont
été malheureusement touchés heureusement
quand on voit la situation il y a pas de
il y a pas de victimes et c'est heureux
parce que quand on voit le l'impact il
est énorme je voudrais
apporter aussi un témoignage sur la
question des ponts puisque j'étais le
co-rapporteur de cette mission
d'information et rappeler quand même que
effectivement le chantier qui s'ouvre
devant nous est immense puisque nous
parlons de près de 250 000 ouvrages
d'art sur pays les ponts communaux fort
heureusement ne représentent que 50 000
et
nous avons des ponts qui pour la grande
majorité d'entre eux datent de la prière
et donc c'est pas un problème nouveau
qui arrive on se saisit de cette
question de l'état sanitaire des
ouvrages et il est heureux que nous
puissions compter sur l'expertise du
céréma pour accompagner les maires je
tiens à préciser qu'il y a plus de 50 %
d'entre eux qui ont reçu un premier
diagnostic sans doute que des
diagnostics approfondis vont être
nécessaires mais ça leur donne déjà une
vision de l'état sanitaire de leur
ouvrage par contre se pose deux facto
tant qu'on n'est pas au courant de la
maladie on n'est pas au courant quand on
est au courant de l'état sanitaire de
l'ouvrage se pose de facto la question
de la responsabilité et aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de merde n'auront pas
d'autre choix que d'interdire le passage
sur un certain nombre d'ouvrages tant
aujourd'hui ils sont au courant du
caractère de dangerosité de l'ouvrage
alors il y a quelque chose des choses
qui pourra être fait sans doute de
manière rapide mais ça relève peut-être
plus du ministre des Transports c'est
d'adopter une signalisation sur ces
ponts qui soient en adéquation avec leur
état réel et pas leur état supposé je
m'explique aujourd'hui nous avons des
ponts qui sont franchis avec des
indications de tonnage qui ne
correspondent plus à l'état sanitaire de
l'ouvrage en question et puis comme on
le fait peut-être pour les ascenseurs
lorsqu'il y a les visites on a une
plaque avec la date de la dernière
visite il faudra peut-être imaginer
demain sur un certain nombre d'ouvrages
ceci ce système de plaque avec la date
des dernières visites pour en terminer
nous avions soutenu l'idée d'un carnets
de santé et je pense que il nous faudra
vérifier que dans le temps cette
question là est correctement appréhendée
et qu'on est le soutien au niveau de
pour se doter d'un outil qui nous
permette d'agréger l'ensemble de la vie
de l'ouvrage et d'en conserver
durablement les données pour que à
l'avenir on puisse connaître et avoir
une traçabilité de ce qui est intervenu
des interventions qui ont été faites sur
l'ouvrage
merci chers collègues
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre nous travaillons
actuellement sur la question du de la
mise en oeuvre du 0 artificialisation
nette autrement dit du zan le zan est un
élément structurant personne n'en
conteste les fondements
idéologique je dirais puisqu'il s'agit
d'un élément structurant de
l'aménagement du territoire pour les
collectivités or à ce jour il y a pas
d'accompagnement de l'État pas de moyens
d'ingénierie des délais intenables des
injonctions contradictoires
relocalisation déploiement des ENR on en
parle en ce moment quel incidence ça
aura c'est problématique est source
d'une grande inquiétude pour les élus
souvent démunies notamment pour les
petites communes quelles actions
prévoyez-vous dans ce domaine pour
éviter d'accroître la rétention foncière
parce que c'est ce qu'on redoute dans la
Commission et d'accepter d'accentuer les
fractures entre territoires et
accompagnés au mieux les collectivités
mais j'ai une autre question à vous
poser sur l'ADEME ça tombe bien parce
que quand on arrive en fin de course
comme ça souvent des questions ont été
posées elles sont redondantes mais cela
ne vous a pas été posée
je suis membre du Conseil administration
de l'ADEME et depuis quatre mois la
présidence de l'ADEME n'a pas été
renouvelée il s'agit quand même d'un
outil extrêmement important pour la
transition écologique et le fait qu'il
n'est pas été renouvelé c'est sans doute
un politique mais peut-être allez vous
pouvoir nous éclairer s'agit-il
s'agit-il de la volonté de ne pas
renouveler le président d'une agence
d'accompagnement à la transition
adaptation à laquelle les territoires
sont très attachés et je peux vous
assurer que celle situation jette un
trouble certains et une confusion même
dans les services de cet instant sur la
ligne défendue par le gouvernement en
matière de projet et j'aimerais que vous
nous éclairiez sur ce sujet si c'est une
volonté de délibérer de supprimer
l'ADEME fait nous le savoir et en tout
cas les salariés eux sont inquiets sur
la direction qui est que l'ADEME va
prendre dans les mois qui viennent parce
qu'ils sont pas pilotés pour l'instant
merci
je vais donner la parole à Hervé j'y
vais
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous avez souligné juste raison
l'impact des événements que nous avons
vécu concernant les incendies hors norme
sur le département de la Gironde et de
l'attention que vous porterez à ces
événements et en rappelant l'habitation
que le Président de la République nous a
fait donc vendredi prochain bien
évidemment j'y répondrai et j'y
assisterai dans ce cadre là la préfète
de région madame buchiot a saisi je
pense le ministère ou le gouvernement
pour voir si elle pouvait obtenir une
rallonge des crédits 2tr et des îles
orientée bien sûr en direction des
communes qui ont été directement un
paquets impactés cette demande a été
relayée sur le plan parlementaire je
l'ai également effectué elle me semble
tout à fait justifiée pourquoi parce que
ces communes qui au-delà évidemment de
l'événement qu'elles ont subi ont
également doivent faire face à des
investissements et des frais
relativement importants consécutifs donc
à ces incendies et en fait la meilleure
réaction en termes d'agilité aujourd'hui
serait qu'elle puisse bonifier une part
de Dr et de désir en termes de
solidarité
départementale et national donc je
voulais donc vous réinterpeller sur ce
sujet qui me paraît effectivement
particulièrement adapté à la situation
l'autre point que je voulais évoquer
avec vous c'est concernant la nouvelle
génération des CER
2021-2027 il faut reconnaître et je
pense que c'est partager par l'ensemble
de nos collègues que nous manquons
aujourd'hui d'informations de clarté de
transparence sur d'abord l'exécution des
anciens CPER entre les autorisations
d'engagement les crédits programmés
l'exécution en fait en tant que tel et
on manque donc de lisibilité même
de mise en perspective sur les nouveaux
CPR par rapport au crédit qui pourrait
être alloué et ce sont des éléments
intéressants pour nous au titre de la
commission pour apprécier effectivement
l'effort de la contractualisation sur ce
sujet il y a également une inquiétude
dans ce cadre là c'est sur les cpiar qui
ont beaucoup de mal à pour le coup aussi
à ce conclure et à s'établir alors qu'il
y a des sujets interrégionaux notamment
sur les politiques de l'eau prenons cet
exemple là sur la région
nouvelle-aquitaine et la région
Occitanie par exemple avec les
événements là aussi que l'on connaît
même à l'heure actuelle puisqu'on on est
contraint de faire du soutien d'étiages
après les périodes Haddock donc de fin
octobre et qui montre qu'il faut avancer
sur ces sujets sur des politiques de
bassins et donc
interrégional je voudrais terminer
également sur un sujet qui n'a pas été
abordé sur les maisons France services
si on peut noter qu'au travers des
enquêtes qui ont été faites il y a
globalement un niveau de satisfaction
intéressant il n'en demeure pas moins
qu'il n'y a pas aujourd'hui à ma
connaissance une méthode d'évaluation
partagée et comparer sur le plan
national qui permet vraiment de situer
la mobilisation de l'offre de service en
fonction de chaque maison française et
on peut constater quand même parfois
certaines hétérogénéités et comme il n'y
a pas d'évaluation nationale et de
modèles partagés on peut pas non plus
avoir un regard suffisamment objectif
aujourd'hui sur la mise en œuvre de
l'offre de service ce qui serait
diablement intéressant puisque vous avez
parlé d'un livre 2 en quelque sorte de
la mobilisation des maisons France
service je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Préville
d'abord sur le fond vert et pour vous
demander des précisions pardon sur j'ai
cru comprendre donc l'englobe
l'enveloppe globale était de 2 milliards
d'euros ça c'est le Global vous avez
parlé après de 200 millions d'euros par
département
pour les départements d'accord très bien
et donc sans appel à projet avec des
projets qui partiront d'initiative des
élus c'est à dire des projets ascendants
en quelque sorte donc des précisions sur
quel instance va statuer est-ce que cela
passera comme les dossiers DTR par le
préfet
et quels seront le champ le périmètre de
ce que pourront proposer les élus ça
c'est ma première question deuxième
question sur le les fortes inquiétudes
bien sûr vous le savez des élus sur le
surcoût d'énergie je vous ai posé une
question auquel vous avez répondu et je
vous en remercie mais qu'est-ce que vous
pensez d'une éventuelle DGF qui serait
indexée sur l'inflation et qui
permettrait peut-être en partie de
répondre à ces questions là ensuite sur
le zan l'adaptation à la ruralité est
absolument nécessaire vous l'avez
souligné car moi je fais remonter ce qui
est en train de se mettre en place sur
le département avec que le travail qui
est fait sur les pluies et de fortes
inquiétudes et incompréhension des élus
sur les permis de construire auxquels
ils pourront prétendre et parce que dans
mon département le lot avec les tournées
que je fais dans les communes il remonte
que dans les Bours il y a pratiquement
plus rien à vendre tous ces vendus
pendant la période covid et que il
propose les élus des changements de
destination notamment parce qu'on a un
certain nombre de Granges qui sont des
bâtiments en pierre et qui ne sont plus
utilisés parce qu'il y a un gros
groupement des des
fermes et que donc on aurait une
possibilité mais que sur par exemple un
territoire de 92 communes qui est une
intercommunalité il y a 200 changements
de destination qui sont proposés et là
tout de suite on dit ah non non ça ne
doit être exceptionnel donc voilà
pourquoi je pense qu'il faudra se
pencher sur les spécificités des
différents départements regarder les
possibilités
qu'évidemment les communes devraient
avoir de pouvoir se développer malgré
tout et des impossibilités par ailleurs
si les changements de destination sont
tout de suite sanctionnés parce qu'on ne
peut pas en faire trop ça ne devrait
être exceptionnel voilà c'était sur ce
sujet là et le dernier sujet et je tiens
à insister comme mes collègues sur le
recrutement des secrétaires de mairie
qui est un problème qui remonte de de
mes visites communales et surtout sur la
formation les dispositifs changent
continuellement il y a des injonctions à
faire plein de choses différentes et il
y a absolument besoin de formation donc
c'est pour voilà vous interroger sur ce
que l'État pourrait mettre en place pour
aider à la formation des secrétaires de
mairie merci
bien madame la ministre je vous ai
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention nous
présenter vos intentions qui sont
louables qui sont frappés d'une
connaissance toutes ces notoriale des
collectivités locales
je vous ai écouté également évoquer la
liste des millions quand ce n'est pas
les milliards d'euros qui sont censés
accompagner ces intentions et je me
laissais je dois l'avouer bercer par
votre voix calme et apaisante
surtout dans ce contexte de plus en plus
intimiste à cette heure-ci et ça me
rappelait d'ailleurs ce que Voltaire
fait dire à Pangloss les choses ne
peuvent être autrement car tout est en
fait pour une fin tout est
nécessairement pour la meilleure fin
tout est au mieux dans le meilleur des
mondes possibles
mais face au panglos de l'État il
m'arrive parfois de me souvenir que je
suis également un candide conseiller
municipal de Digoin et je sais que
demain matin je vais retrouver la dure
réalité que vivent beaucoup de
collectivités locales et moi je voudrais
revenir sur le vrai sujet que nous
vivons lorsque je me retrouve au conseil
municipal c'est la réalité de ces
collectivités trop grandes pour
bénéficier des tarifs réglementés de
l'électricité mais qui n'ont pas
forcément les reins assez solides pour
absorber l'explosion de leur facture
énergétique et ce comme disent mes
collègues lorsqu'ils me voient partir le
mardi matin
c'est demande-leur demande à la ministre
ce qu'elle va vraiment faire pourquoi
nous n'avons pas droit au tarif
réglementés pourquoi le gouvernement
n'entend pas élargir le nombre des
collectivités qui peuvent bénéficier de
ces tarifs peut-être que ce n'est pas
dans votre périmètre de compétences mais
est-ce que c'est sur votre feuille la
route au regard des conséquences que ça
sur beaucoup de collectivités un
objectif que vous vous êtes fixé est-ce
que vous souhaitez obtenir cela lors
d'un débat en séance il nous avait été
dit il y a quelques temps que c'était
l'Union européenne les règlementations
européennes qui
l'empêchait lorsqu'on évoque cela avec
les dirigeants de DF il nous disent que
au regard de la situation actuelle sur
l'énergie s'il y a une volonté de l'État
il y a possibilité d'aller sur ce type
de mesure d'ailleurs l'Espagne a montré
combien on pouvait parfois sortir des
carcans que l'on croyait intangible
deuxième question sur le filet de
sécurité parce que j'imagine que vous
allez me répondre là dessus bien sûr que
c'est une mesure bienvenu et on va en
bénéficier localement vous avez annoncé
que des acomptes pouvaient être versés
avant même la fin de l'année ce qui
semble un peu audacieux puisque par
définition il faut avoir les comptes
2022 pour pouvoir savoir si on en
bénéficie donc est-ce que ceux qui
auront des acomptes et qui finalement ne
serait plus un ou deux pour cent prêts
ne pourrait pas finalement est-ce que
vous allez leur demander de rembourser
les sommes et les et les acomptes et
pour 2023 puisque bien sûr cette
dégradation est progressive souvent on a
pris un premier coup avec l'augmentation
du gaz d'électricité en 2022 et on va
encore avoir des des nouvelles encore
pire en 2023 qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez mettre en place sur sur 2023
quel dispositif
je voudrais également parce que je vous
ai également je le disais
écoutez très attentivement lorsque vous
dites que vous souhaitez garantir des
moyens d'agir et d'investir pour les
collectivités et pour cela un soutien
accru de l'État vous permettrez quand
même là aussi de relayer le fait que 320
millions d'euros de plus pour la DGF
c'est toujours mieux que s'il n'était
pas là bien sûr mais lorsque vous vous
satisfaisez de des 95% de collectivités
qui vont connaître une stabilité de
leurs moyens dans le cadre d'une
inflation à 6 ou 7 6 ou 7 % d'inflation
vous permettrait quand même aux élus
locaux de considérer que le et bien que
ce n'est pas satisfaisant et j'en
profiterai d'ailleurs pour vous demander
si parce que c'est une une question qui
revient beaucoup sur le terrain de
combien les bases des impositions
foncières vont être valorisées puisque
contrairement à ce qu'on pratiquait
beaucoup dans les collectivités
aujourd'hui tous on pense à préparer les
budgets dès cet automne pour faire face
aux difficultés et ne pas attendre le
mois de mars ou d'avril pour faire les
choix budgétaires qui vont s'imposer et
pour terminer puisque j'ai entendu mon
excellent collègue Bigot parler de
l'ADEME dire que la nomination était
suspendue alors je ne pense pas que le
gouvernement attendent de pouvoir nommer
un ancien Premier ministre à
à ce poste lui laissant le temps
peut-être d'expérimenter d'autres
fonctions plus sérieusement puisque
effectivement cette nomination semble
suspendue au temps suspente on vol ne
pourrait-on pas proposer madame la
ministre vous qui défendez les
collectivités locales finalement qu'on
puisse également suspendre l'application
de la TGAP sur tout ce qui est collecte
et traitement des déchets ménagers c'est
une vraie réalité qu'on vit tous dans
nos territoires actuellement c'est une
une progression qui est bienvenu au
regard du caractère incitatif qu'elle
doit avoir mais aujourd'hui cette TGAP
qui explose fait que les redevances et
les taxes d'ordures ménagères dans les
budgets des collectivités locales certes
ce sont souvent des budgets annexes
pourraient beaucoup gloser là-dessus
mais tout de même ça reste une réalité
et pour le contribuable demain ce sera
également en 2022 et en 2023 une hausse
très importante je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre merci pour votre présence
devant nous cet après-midi
j'essaierai d'être rapide j'aurais un
point d'alerte à vous donner et une
interrogation en questionnement le point
d'alerte va dans le sens quand évoqué
plusieurs de mes collègues concernant
les tarifs de l'énergie qui mettent
actuellement en péril beaucoup de
collectivités territoriales soit dans
leur budget intrinsèque soit à travers
leur service public qu'elle n'arrive
plus à honorer donc c'est ce point
d'alerte que je souhaite vous faire
personnellement je le vois dans mon
département des Pyrénées-Atlantiques
c'est vraiment une problématique
aujourd'hui relayée par l'association
des maires
et qui sera très vite relayée au niveau
national donc effectivement alors vous
avez répondu bouclier tarifaire à
travers l'augmentation de la DGF
permettez-moi de vous dire je pense que
ça ne sera pas suffisant madame la
ministre et en attendant que l'Europe se
met d'accord oui on nous suivons tous
les différentes réunions européennes
je pense pour ma part que et j'espère
qu'elle y arrivera à se mettre d'accord
donc à la fois sur les TRV les tarifs
réglementés de vente qui seraient
effectivement un bouclier très important
j'ai bon espoir que puisque nous avons
l'état décidé que EDF serait 100% état à
travers ce levier là j'espère que le
gouvernement pourra décider assez
rapidement des tarifs réglementés de
vente qui seront un capage important
effectivement pour les collectivités
territoriales donc et puis
la décorrélation entre le prix du gaz et
de l'électricité qui
dépend de la décision européenne et pour
laquelle je pense nous sommes un peu
plus éloignés quand même de la décision
donc ce point d'alerte madame la
ministre augmentation de la DGS à mes
yeux ce ne sera pas suffisant il faudra
à mon sens parce que vous serez
interpellé vous et l'ensemble du
gouvernement
seront vous serez interpellés lors de la
du prochain congrès des marques de
France sur ce sujet bien présent
donc il vous faudra y répondre avec avec
des mesures certainement un peu plus
concrètes pourquoi ne pas individualiser
les réponses en fonction des
des dégages je dirais que fait cette
augmentation d'énergie sur les
collectivités locales peut-être qu'il
vous faudra effectivement
individualiser les aides par rapport à
ces communes-là pour qu'elle puisse
franchir le cap de l'équilibre de leur
budget ça c'était le point d'alerte
madame la ministre deuxièmement
locationnement très simple et très
rapide à quand
nous pourrons voir la gestion de la DGCI
au niveau départemental aujourd'hui
cette gestion de dgcilles est faite au
niveau régional les préfets de
départements font ce qu'ils peuvent en
fonction des demandes qu'ils ont dans
leur département je crois que et c'est
la demande des collectivités
territoriales elles veulent une gestion
beaucoup plus proche de leur territoire
et de leur collectivité dans cette un
questionnement madame la ministre je
vous remercie
bien madame Lamy je vous propose de
répondre à mes collègues merci
[Musique]
monsieur Tabaro est revenu je vais
répondre à sa question le sur le
versement des dotations de soutien suite
au catastrophes naturelles elles exigent
des inspections préalables pour évaluer
les prises en charge ça c'est un premier
point d'autre part les délais justement
ont été allongés en raison hélas du
nombre
d'intempéries mais nous travaillons à
réduire au maximum les délais avant le
versement de l'aide aux collectivités
je sais pas si j'ai répondu à question
mais bon alors si c'est parfait je m'en
réjouis ensuite je crois qu'il y avait
monsieur Bigot monsieur le sénateur oui
sur le zan
vous savez je dirais que les
collectivités territoriales elles ont
beaucoup fait aujourd'hui je dirais et
il faut que l'État intensifie son
dialogue et son accompagnement c'est la
consigne qu'a formulé
Christophe Béchu pour ralentir la
procédure et préférer la concertation à
l'obligation verticale il en demeure pas
moins que l'objectif devra être
poursuivi et je sais pas si je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure mais il a invité à une
mission il a confié une mission au
sénateur de toute tendance politique sur
une mission de réflexion sur la mise en
œuvre du zan alors je sais pas si
certains d'entre vous
participent oui voilà donc
ce que nous voulons c'est mettre en
oeuvre certes mais la mettre en oeuvre
avec discernement et non pas dans dans
la douleur et la sobriété foncière elle
est bien sur l'objectif mais j'ai
compris que nous la partagerons tous
mais le regard de l'état local doit être
équilibrée et juste et puis je crois que
les collectivités devront être
accompagnés dans la mise en oeuvre de
leur démarche de dans le cadre de la
de la sobriété foncière pardon et puis
nous mobiliserons aussi des outils
d'ingénierie pour fournir les données
nécessaires et pour accompagner les
collectivités
les premiers éléments de dialogue pour
déjà sur la clarification de la
nomenclature et sur la prise en compte
des efforts de renaturation qui seraient
fait par les élus d'ici 2030 donc en
fait nous attendons à la compte rend de
la mission d'expertise qui a été lancée
et je peux vous dire aussi que
Christophe Béchu a lancé une mission à
des urbanistes pour essayer justement de
comprendre quels étaient les mesures les
plus concrètes et les plus adaptés à
mettre en œuvre voilà ce que je peux
vous dire sur le zan parce que nous en
sommes là et nous avions dit que nous
travaillerions avant jusqu'au mois de
janvier pour réunir de nouveau les élus
autour de la table alors cyril pelvat
est parti mais je vais quand même vous
donner la réponse sur la fiscalité des
résidences secondaires dans les communes
touristiques littorales montagnes
l'enjeu en fait c'est que le système
fiscal sur les résidences non
principales est actuellement complexe et
il prend insuffisamment en compte les
communes touristiques et les effets de
la saisonnalité beaucoup de la maison ou
d'appartements sont inoccupés 10 ou 11
mois par an et pose un problème dans la
rareté du logement pour certaines
communes la première partie du PLF 2023
revoit donc le zonage des logements
vacances pour prendre en compte les
communes touristiques avec des locations
saisonnières c'est un amendement du
groupe Renaissance concrètement un
nombre plus important de communes
notamment touristique pourront instaurer
la majoration taxes d'habitation de la
taxe d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires donc le PLF 2023 propose
concrètement d'étendre les périmètres
zones tendus en fonction de la tension
immobilière en fonction des prix élevés
à l'achat et à la location et en
fonction de la proportion élevée de
résidence secondaire par rapport à
l'ensemble du parc de logements dans ces
communes dont la liste va être établie
par décret les en vacances seront aussi
imposées directement au bout d'un an de
vacances volontaires tandis que les
exécutifs locaux c'est à dire les mers
pourront choisir d'y renforcer le niveau
d'imposition locale en majorant la taxe
d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires
voilà mais ça sera à la volonté des
mères rien ne sera évidemment imposé
alors ensuite qu'est-ce qui m'avait posé
des questions il y avait
il y avait madame filleul oui
le plan France nature verte qu'a
présenté la première ministre la semaine
dernière
va mobiliser en transversalité
de nombreux ministères partant
évidemment du pôle environnement et
transitions écologique de Christophe
Béchu du pôle de d'Agnès panier runacher
et nous allons travailler ensemble pour
une meilleure solidarité entre nos
territoires on va pas opposer les villes
aux rurales et les villes aux campagnes
donc ce qu'on veut c'est un équilibre
dans l'aménagement du territoire mais
la transition écologique passera par les
territoires et sera mis en œuvre
évidemment par les communes les intérêts
communalité
et mais nous allons
j'allais dire proposer un certain nombre
de mesures et c'est ces mesures dans le
cadre du Plan vert que les dons
devraient se saisir les communes et les
intercommunalités
la NCT va gérer les 25 millions
d'ingénierie vertes pas les 20 millions
d'ingénierie dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure dans le cadre de la NCT mais
bien une enveloppe 25 millions 25 oui
c'est ça millions d'euros en ingénierie
verte qui seront sortis du plan des deux
milliards et c'est la NCT qui va gérer
cette ingénierie entre guillemets verte
voilà ce que je peux vous dire à l'heure
actuelle sur le plan vert
alors ceux qui m'ont posé monsieur Bigot
et
Monsieur
Genet m'ont parlé de la dame ça n'est
pas de mon ressort
et sachez évidemment que nous sommes
très vigilants sur cette
l'ADEME et qui est pour nous un
interlocuteur privilégié mais c'est pas
moi qui peut vous donner des
informations là-dessus ensuite sur
monsieur gilet qui m'avait parlé du
contrat de plan état région j'ai bien
noté votre remarque sur le manque
d'information je vais donc demander à la
DGCL de bien vouloir tenir informer les
communes le plus vite possible pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de surprise par
rapport à ses fonds et sur la dotr des
cils dans le cadre des incendies la
totalité des enveloppes déotr déciles
sont délégués au préfet sur la base
d'une enveloppe calculée selon des
critères législatifs néanmoins nous nous
pourrons en parler vendredi puisque je
serait aussi présente
aux côtés de des acteurs de la sécurité
civile mais pensez bien que nous allons
porter une attention particulière aux
communes qui ont été sinistrés par les
incendies
et ça sera un sujet abordé pendant cette
réunion
sur la madame simple vous m'avez
interrogé où est-ce qu'elle est Madame
sur la desciles au département la loi
3DS a permis la délégation de signature
pour la décile du préfet de région au
préfet département donc en fait vous
aurez quelques entre guillemets avec
tout le respect que je leur dois un
circuit court qui est possible grâce à
cette disposition de la loi 3DS et cela
je pense répondra à la demande de
proximité des élus
monsieur Genet c'est vous après des
propos extrêmement chaleureux avec un
peu d'humour je le concède sur les bases
elles seront revalorisées en fonction de
l'inflation puisqu'elles sont indexées
et nous nous opposons au gouvernement
aux amendements qui sont portés par
certains groupes sur leur de les caper
parce que nous par contre ce que nous
voulons c'est obtenir que puisse être
délié et que les mères quand on arrivera
à l'année prochaine à 7 ou 8
d'augmentation ils puissent
voter une baisse de cette de cette base
mais nous en sommes là mais nous
n'accepterons pas qu'elle soit capée de
toute façon voilà moi je pense que
de par mon expérience et là je réfléchis
à titre totalement personnel que quand
les habitants viendront montrer leurs
feuilles d'impôts les élus quels qu'ils
soient seront forcément
interpeller mais que si les besoins se
font sentir les mères jugeront ou pas
utiles de maintenir cette augmentation
des bases ou j'espère qu'ils pourront
négocier va baisser
l'ampleur l'amplitude de l'augmentation
de la base voilà
est-ce que cela dessus ce que je réponds
à la question d'accord ensuite vous
m'avez parlé du filet de sécurité
2022 avec une avance dès le 15 novembre
j'ai répondu mais je pense qu'il faudra
que les préfets et la liste des communes
sans attendre la troisième la troisième
clause troisième comment tu dis critères
oui bon un autre filet de sécurité 2023
va être débattue à l'Assemblée nationale
avec une augmentation de la DGF qui va
porter sur la DSR donc les communes
rurales mais il pourra y avoir des
amendements augmentant ces 300 vingt
millions d'euros nous verrons ça ce qui
se passe ici ou ce qui se décide à
l'Assemblée nationale
alors est-ce que vous voulez que je
revienne sur le bouclier sur
l'électricité je crois que c'est vous
aussi bon alors le tarif réglementé de
vente pour les petites communes avec un
plafonnement à 15% maximum de
l'augmentation 28 000 communes devraient
être concernées
et bien pour les autres nous attendons
de savoir quel est leur fragilité si
elle rentre ou pas dans ce genre de
bouclier
non parce que
le bouclier est un réglementé il faut
une commune de moins de oui c'est moins
de d'accord mais après ça vous avez le
filet de sécurité
pardon pourquoi madame la ministre on ne
se bat pas pour dire que toutes les
collectivités qui ont moins de je sais
pas 50 millions de budget et 300
personnes peuvent bénéficier de cet
arrêt réglementés pourquoi on élargit
pas la base du nombre de communes qui
relèvent de ce tarif réglementé ce qui
ensuite 15% on peut effectivement un
centre de communes peuvent absorber une
augmentation de 15% et ce serait et
serait très preneur d'une augmentation
qui serait limitée à 15% et pas 300 600
800 % d'augmentation comme la commune de
Gueugnon à côté de chez moi qui ne sait
plus comment faire parce que elle a 8000
habitants elle elle ne peut pas
bénéficier de ses tarifs réglementés
alors au Conseil des ministres de ce
matin vous voyez c'est tout frais on a
parlé de modalités d'extension à toutes
les collectivités qui pourraient être
annoncées dans les prochains jours
c'est donc pour vous permettre de faire
ce teasing madame
filet de sécurité c'est clair c'est
clair pour tout le monde bon alors
ensuite qu'est-ce qui reste à qui je
n'ai pas répondu à Monsieur gold qui est
parti
madame Préville c'était sur quoi déjà
sur le fond vert oui le fond vert tout à
l'heure j'ai dit en intervention
liminaire que ces deux milliards
seraient à la main des élus qui pourrait
proposer qui devront proposer leurs
projets à leur préfet de département ou
de région avec la variante des millions
d'ingénierie vertes de la portée par la
NCT pour les aider à les mettre en œuvre
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
exemples de projets qui pourraient parce
que chère madame la sénatrice je vais
pas vous donner d'exemples puisqu'ils
vont dépendre de vos communes les
exemples alors forcément un périmètre
alors je vais vous dire par exemple la
renaturation en ville les isolation
thermique des bâtiments des écoles
voilà le plantation d'arbres également
le fond friche qui va être
qui perdurera justement pour permettre
à la fois en ville ou en périphérie de
ne pas dépendre d'usage mais qui
permettra de remettre en valeur des
terrains constructibles voilà ce sont
tous ces dispositifs là qui seront à la
disposition des élus
sur la vidéo et sur
la DGF la première ministre s'y est
opposée
monsieur gilet ah Monsieur gilet
la question de l'évaluation partagée des
maisons France services à l'heure
actuelle on n'a pas de référentiel
commun d'évaluation sur les maisons
France service
donc c'est intéressant parce que quand
même les beaucoup d'opérateurs d'État
ont des référentiels d'évaluation qui
sont communs qui sont partagées et qui
permettent d'objectiver le
fonctionnement
donc de l'offre de service qu'en
pensez-vous j'en pense du bien monsieur
le sénateur je vais y réfléchir et je
vais en parler à Stanislas Guérini qui a
les maisons France services dans ces
responsabilités puisque je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure que nous préparions une
étape suivante avec nos partenaires il y
a neuf opérateurs qui participent aux
maisons France service je sais qu'il y
en a qu'il y a des maisons francs
services qui marchent d'une manière
exceptionnelle il y en a d'autres où
c'est peut-être un peu plus difficile
j'en suis parfaitement consciente et
nous allons travailler là je vais lui
dire que ça serait bien que nous ayons
un peu un état des lieux et une
évaluation voilà
oui
madame la ministre vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure à Monsieur Geney et à moi
que
la décision de
choisir un président pour l'ADEME ne
vous appartenez pas alors à qui faut-il
s'adresser parce que Monsieur Béchu a
dit que chaque jour qui passe nous
rapproche du moment où la décision sera
prise ce qui est d'une clarté limpide
mais j'aimerais plus de précisions s'il
vous plaît
je vais pas prendre des positions sur la
dame
de quel ministère je pense que c'est
peut-être celui de Christophe Béchu ou
c'est Agnès panière une haché peut-être
en salaire bien clair non mais je suis
désolé vous pouvez pas me demander de
vous répondre sur quelque chose qui ne
m'appartient pas voilà
mais
moi ce que je voudrais revenir c'est sur
l'effort que nous avons approche du
moment où la décision sera prise ça j'ai
noté ça doit être prisé elle va être
prise incessamment je voudrais
simplement venir sur je voudrais
simplement revenir sur les 320 millions
de DGF parce que c'est un effort
important qui est fait pour stabiliser
les choses et si vous mettez bout à bout
le fond vert les les aides le bouclier
sur le bouclier sur l'électricité le
filet de sécurité et le bouclier
tarifaire je pense qu'on arrive quand
même à des budgets conséquents au
service des collectivités pour lutter
contre l'inflation et pour les aider à
se lancer dans la rénovation thermique
et écologique donc je crois que et le
filet de sécurité
et le bouclier sur l'électricité sont
importants ajoutés aux 320 millions de
DG
n'oubliez quand même pas que c'est la
première fois depuis 13 ans que la DGF
qu'on touche à la DGF
après les baisses de quelques dizaines
de milliards du gouvernement Hollande
donc je le rappelle quand même l'année
dernière elle est dotations n'avait pas
baissé cette année il y a un bonus et
voilà je souhaitais rappeler cette
ce bonus donné aux collectivités et puis
vous redire aussi à la fois que nous
sommes à votre disposition mais que nous
sommes nombreux à être issus de vos
rangs des rangs municipaux de présidente
département de conseillers régionaux
dans ce gouvernement et qu'à ce titre il
faut nous faire le crédit de vouloir
protéger et travailler au service de nos
collectivités
je suis toujours à votre disposition
pour aller sur le terrain cela va sans
dire
bien Madame la Ministre merci
deux heures d'audition merci pour vos
réponses merci pour ces échanges et j'ai
noté
une de vos phrases qui m'a effectivement
réjouit par rapport à ce qu'on a fait ce
matin c'est que j'ai bien noté que vous
avez indiqué que la transition
écologique passera par les territoires
et c'est bien effectivement notre
volonté de faire passer la transition
écologique par nos territoires merci
Madame la Ministre merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs et
sénateurs merci pour votre écoute
et si vous avez d'autres questions on
vous les on essaiera d'y répondre